so we're using direct to access a local
installation of PubMed
I'm Peter Cooper and as I said Jonathan
Cahn's is the sort of mind behind eat
erect in the hands and the work behind
you directly he's online with us and Ben
Busby is here as well and my colleague
so we're all here to answer your
questions what we're gonna do today is
we're going to learn to use a direct to
archive PubMed a local solid-state drive
we're gonna see how we can access the
data using some of the functions that
are now available any direct through
fetch records and we'll also just point
out you that you can also search for
terms although I won't demonstrate that
today today we're just going to show you
the basics of how to fetch records out
of there we'll also point out some new
features of the extract program and some
other redirect strips scripts that will
just point out to you that you can
process you know the data that you get
from pubmed locally with extract really
without having to write any additional
scripts that's the main powerful thing
about extract ok just a reminder if you
don't know what entre direct is that
would be useful to know about if you're
going to do this webinar but anyway you
might be able to get caught up if you
check it out this is a command line
version basically of the e-utilities
which are the API for the entre system
saying that is a little bit limiting in
terms of what edirect can do in
particular because it has processing
scripts and it has an XML parser called
extract that are probably the most
powerful aspects of these programs the
search programs I mean the retrieval
programs each output XML that can be
piped directly into another direct
program or a Linux utility of course you
need to have a UNIX or Linux like
environment to run this today we're
going to be demonstrating things on a
Mac and the documentation is there and
there's a very good manual that has lots
and lots of examples and so you can link
to that to find out more about e direct
well here's just a diagram that shows
you the difference some of the different
functions or different programs that are
in direct basically the idea is you can
run a search then you can retrieve
things from the history server using a
fetch program and you can process those
outputs what's going to happen today
though is we're going to show you that
you can use a script that will fetch
things from a local instance of PubMed
and then you can use extract to parse
that XML we did do a webinar any direct
quite a while ago but it's still very
useful if you want to check that out
it's a link there on this slide and
that's in our webinars playlist on our
YouTube channel so you know many people
are interested in text mining PubMed in
particular the abstracts and so if you
take some human disease mesh term like
this one heart disease and you do a
search you get a lot of Records this
isn't you get a lot more for other kinds
of searches but this is about six
hundred thirty thousand abstracts and
you can you know go to the send to menu
in the entree web system and select file
and download records you can do this
with any entree database this case you
could get the XML of the PubMed which
contains the abstract and you could try
to download this this will probably not
work it's too large of a set to do this
way and even our AP is and in this case
I'm just showing you each search but
it's really a proxy for any kind of API
that any kind of program or a script
that's going to be using the utilities
even those are going to be slow here's
just basically what the history server
tells us there's six hundred thirty
thousand records that have abstracts
which we already knew from that web
search and I could write a command line
with piping that into a fetch or I could
use fetch if I was using it on the
utilities and I could just try to
download this what you'll find is that
probably won't work at least not in one
fell swoop
that's too many it's too slow just a
reminder that the network service that
the api's are accessing is a very busy
shared resources and the access speed to
that and the volume that you can get
from that is limited so you know there
are lots of ways around that we're going
to talk about a way today that well
helped a lot I think one thing you could
do is get all the PubMed now of course
you cannot do it by going to the web
there are 18 million abstracts but you
could download this by FTP as you
probably know you can now download
PubMed bed line from NLM without the
need to apply for a license and you can
get basically the full XML dump of
PubMed there's an annual baseline and
you can get Gale the update files once
you downloaded the problem is you're
faced with several problems but one of
them is that there's no provide a means
of random access you basically have an
XML dump the extract parser can parse it
but you're gonna have to process the
entire set in some way and that's a big
deal
and just so you know there are lots of
people that want to do these kinds of
things and been pointed out to me the
other day that there were two sort of
programs cluster duck and purse these
are basically pipelines basically to
work off of downloading things from
PubMed and they could be made to run on
a local version of PubMed they in fact
would benefit greatly from using the
sort of strategy that we're going to
talk about today okay so you know this
problem of the local instance of PubMed
edirect has a solution thanks to
Jonathan and there's some scripts that
now come with interact that will install
an update a puppet and allow you to
access it so there's a script called
archive PubMed that will install and
update a local instance a local data
cache of PubMed it uses our FTP site it
downloads the files from there and key
and you can use it to keep it updated
this particular solution uses the Apple
file system on a solid-state drive to
store records in the sort of
hierarchical index folder system it uses
the Apple file system because that
allows you to have millions of files and
folders talking with Jonathan this is
portable potentially to other file
systems we don't have their real details
on how to do that but it should be
possible and maybe Jonathan as some
things to say about that at the end of
their questions about that there is also
an index pubmed script that does a
similar thing for indexing words and
phrases in the local insolation it uses
the same sort of strategy using the
files and folders and a direct fetch the
fetch which is actually a version of you
fetch a script I should have a different
name for that there can retrieve from
the local cache it's about a hundred
times faster or maybe more than a
hundred times faster than from the
network service and that's probably an
underestimate of how much faster it
would be and then this link at the
bottom of this slide the go us a link
there that will take you directly to the
portion of the e direct documentation
that talks about using the local cache
so here are just some examples and of
course we're not going to try to run
this script today in the webinar because
this will take a long time to sort of
make your installation basically you're
just going to tell it archive PubMed and
then you're going to give it a path to
some drive this is the name of the hard
drive that Jonathan sent me this is rose
and that's where the data is and so this
archived PubMed script will retrieve the
PubMed XML from the FTP site and make
these hierarchical sets of files and
folders it takes about a million folders
to contain 28 million compressed PubMed
records and Jonathan has a system where
that's set up in these sort of
hierarchical folders and there's the
path for example to the folder that
would contain this particular PubMed ID
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so he uses the pairs of
numbers in the PubMed ID to create this
tree and then there are several PubMed
records in that directory but it breaks
the database up into manageable chunks
it also has a feature of cleaning things
up in PubMed XML and you can run
archived PubMed on a weekly basis or
something like that to maintain the
database to keep it current there's also
a similar strategy that you could use to
index this data you can use this index
pubmed script again giving it the
afterwards gonna go and it creates a
hierarchical set of terms and files in
the files and folders analogous to the
way we did with the records and for
example the example linkage Allah gives
them the help document you know you
could go into this volumes directory
rows then there's a postings directory
that has the folders for example
canceler is broken up into this path
that you see here a c / a / and / c and
then all the terms related to cancer are
in there this service allows
unrestricted wild car card truncation so
you can get all the variants of like sir
for example therapy with us asterisk
coming in you can do phrase queries you
can do proximity searches the program
that runs out of the script that does a
local phrase search it's called local
phrase search and we'll give you counts
and it will also pull out the PubMed IDs
for passing the archived PubMed and all
this is happening on this little hard
drive that's about as big as the cell
phone actually it's about the same size
as my cell phone it holds all the PubMed
plus these and mix folders and it's
attached right now it's attached to my
Mac desktop at NCBI but it could be
attached to a Mac laptop and I work just
fine this is about a five this is a 500
gigabyte hard drive that's formatted
with the Apple file system and it's
attached to a Macintosh computer at the
moment and then here is some simple
example command lines that will do some
demos here in a minute
that will use some of these kinds of
things so here's one where I can run a
search typical this is our this is what
we're gonna do today and I'll talk more
about in a minute so I'm trying to get
all the articles from PNAS that have
abstracts I can give the IDS down to
this part the upper part of this command
line is coming from the network service
I'm getting the IDS not the records
themselves and then I can use this fetch
PubMed which is the script that is
looking into local archive here on rows
and I'm going to get all these things
out as XML there are some examples of
local phrase searches again pointing to
the directory on rows this time it's the
postings directory they can count them
or it can get them get the IDS for you
and pass them to fetch pubmed you can
also set an environment variable that
will make it so you don't have to
include that past statement every time
so we're going to do a live demo this is
one that Jonathan provided and it's
pretty cool actually it's kind of a it's
kind of a funny example but it
demonstrates the power of you know using
the local cache for getting records out
and also really the power of extract for
being able to do essentially mining in
PubMed so you're gonna go in there and
do some analysis awesome reformatting
and some calculations just using that
extract program so basically what we're
going to do is look at how the number of
words in PNAS abstracts have changed
over time so we're going to search
PubMed online for all the PNAS abstracts
then we're going to process the pubmed
XML from the local instance using new
extract options just to show you that
there's some additional things you can
do the two new elements I think Jonathan
wanted to emphasize here are the WRP
option which wraps the elements in an
XML objects you rewrite you remake some
XML for further processing and select
which we're going to use to select
records by a particular condition in
this case the year so what I'll do now
is escape out of the slide set and I'm
gonna go over to my Mac desktop and I'll
probably have to log in because it's
probably time doubt on me and then we'll
look at a terminal window there where we
can run some of these scripts and I'm
gonna have to flip back and forth
between the text which you have also in
your handout section on the google
webinar page page there and flip back to
our Mac desktop here okay and so here's
a terminal window with a command prompt
so that's where we're going to be doing
our work so what I'm gonna do is pull up
on the PC side here these are the notes
that are in your and so here is the
kinds of things that we're gonna do
we're gonna run these searches and I'm
going to just copy the command lines
from here and we'll talk about we won't
have time to talk about all the
different things that are in these
command lines I'll point out some
important things so I'm just going to
copy that go over to the Mac desktop
here
I'll paste that command line down now
that's just going to run a search at on
our network service but it's useful just
to show you that so we can see how many
we're going to get 115,000 if we do that
so let's see what the next step is to
get that XML and we're going to this
time we're going to get it locally now
there are some command lines here that
contain this path option here to go into
Rosi to the arc to rose to the archive
directory but if i've already exported
this environment variable here so i
don't have to do that anymore it knows
where to look
so here's the longest thing we're going
to do today I think now they're gonna
have to wait a few seconds for this to
run and this is basically going to go
now take these you IDs that we're
getting from the network server then
we're gonna pass them to the local
instance of PubMed and get them out
using the fetch pubmed script and so
let's run that so when recently it
hasn't taken very long of course twenty
seconds seems like a long time when
you're doing the webinar okay so it did
finish yay and let's just take a look at
what's in there
and so this is going to contain the PNAS
XML for all these different records what
we want to do next is to go in here and
start pulling out data so we want to
pull out the year that you can see there
we also want to go to the abstracts
section of the XML and pull out the
individual words that are in there clear
my terminal here now I save this file as
file in PASM XML you could do this in a
single set of pipe steps but I thought
it was easier just to do this this way
so I have that locally saved that's just
going to put it into the screen so you
can just see what happens what's gonna
go in here is it's gonna avoid that it's
going to not worry about stop words it's
gonna look good in the pubmed article
for the date and it's gonna get the
words from the abstract these are these
sub arguments here in the PF prefix
argument there it is sort of make sure
it all comes out on separate lines so
that would be what you would get you
just go through each one each one of the
records one at a time and get that
information from it now you could
process that of course one of the things
that you could do is you could use a
rather complex looking command line
shown here that would basically insert
XML tags into this thing it's rather
large and complex but it basically would
give you another set of XML the goal
here is we're going to take this XML
we're going to reprocess it by using
extract I won't run this one it would
basically give you that but I will run
the next one which uses is a new option
which is this wrap option and it lets
you say what the tags are going to be
and you can put the data right in there
we're gonna work directly on the PNAS
xml file and i'm going to say that as a
file which I'm calling your underscore
words XML let's make sure that that
worked okay
and it did so we created a set of XML
for each one of the records there that's
going to have the year at the top and
then the individual words that are in
the abstract and again you can do this
to give you another kind of XML it's
going to count the number of words in
each one of the articles so that's the
script here I'll call this counts by
year XML and then we can process that
the rest of the way with the additional
things that are in here and again we're
using that wrap option to make XML tags
and we get the pattern from the new XML
that we had made previously and so
basically this point out that extract
just basically is an XML parser it can
work on any kind of XML as long as it's
valid and we made our own XML here so we
can just take a look at what's in there
and so now we have something that looks
pretty structured and easy to deal with
so that gives you the average number and
that's for each abstract yeah I'm sorry
it's not the average number this is a
number that's a number of words on each
one of the abstracts did you just see
the top here with 2018 so you can see
that there's some variability there what
we want to do is get the average of
those and basically what we'll do is
we'll use extract to use some of the
additional analysis features that are in
extract to do that and so I've got a
Donovan has made a little shell script
here that will do a loop using the years
from 1960 to 2018 and then it's going to
take that within that loop it's going to
use extract and using a different option
the new adoption that's available in
extract to select so it's going to pass
the year it's going to only get the year
when it matches this year and then we're
going to run through the loop and we're
going to get them all together for each
year and we're going to get the average
okay I probably didn't tape it in quite
paste that in quite right but just to
save a little time I'll go ahead and get
the ear accounts just to show you what
it looks like so that's what you have if
you run that shell script properly I'm
gonna get a basically a set of ears with
the corresponding average number for
each year in there and this is why we're
on my Mac desktop because what you can
do is use another script that's in
edirect this XY plot and this is a
script that Jonathan put in there it
uses plot 2 which is a Mac program 1 and
it will give you a nice little chart so
what happened over that span of years to
the word counts in PNAS abstracts and so
the number of words per abstract in
penis has gone up since 1970 69 pretty
much it's kind of leveling off right now
it's probably only so much you can put
in there and so that's the full demo and
at the bottom of the script there's you
can run this basically as a single
script if you want to and the text for
that isn't there well so we're kind of
at time but I'll be happy to leave this
open and we can answer questions so let
me do that now let me just go back over
here to the slides just for a couple of
more points and then we'll have some
questions so we did what we said we saw
you know we did this whole thing be sure
to you that you can download and
maintain an accessible local instance of
PubMed we showed you that the extract
parser and other redirect scripts give
you tools for processing and analyzing
PubMed records and now I hope you know
how to do this and then there's a slide
at the end that you can certainly have
and it's got some URLs for some of the
things we talked about and some of the
things that we haven't talked about just
play
is where you can learn more about NCBI
remember you can always write to us at
info and if you have questions about
webinars in general you can white great
to webinars if you have questions for me
or Jonathan or Ben I think we'll all be
happy to answer emails sent to us so
then do we have any questions we sure do
sound like a deer yeah there were some
discussion about putting stuff on github
and I'm gonna pass that on to Jonathan
no guarantees there but certainly
possible so but the first thing I wanted
to ask Jonathan I remember Jonathan we
had a discussion about this a little
while ago and basically the question can
be boiled down to do you have to use a
Mac or can you use something like sent
to us with a std Drive using the Andrew
file system to use this the Mac ap FS is
why I built it because it by default can
handle millions of folders and files but
there are settings for Linux Windows
systems that one of the attendees
actually sent me and that's that will be
printed out if you're configuring online
X and Windows NTFS there is a way to
customize the file system I just don't
know what it is so I'd like to get
someone who does know what it is to tell
me what to do and then I can add that
advice of documentation so it should be
possible to configure all these file
systems to handle lots and lots of files
that shouldn't be a problem
I believe thee so the source code for
everything is included when you download
entré correct I believe it is copied
automatically to github but again you
can the source code comes with the
deandre direct download someone also in
the chat asked said that extract doesn't
need testing issues tested on a
Raspberry Pi and said the direct
utilities run just fine but the compiled
code extract does not I like that
person to contact me because we did put
up we do now build extract an archive
for Raspberry Pi the ARM processor so if
it's not working I'd like to work with
that person to figure out why it isn't
working get it to work cuz it now should
be standard the download the setup
script should recognize it download it
automatically so if something isn't
quite working we want to get that right
fantastic there's a couple of other real
simple things Jonathan
correct me if I'm wrong here somebody
else if you can use sort unique count
reg to get word frequency and since it's
just rapper of Linux commands you should
be able to use that for when you use
extract for words why not just to
reiterate something Peter said you don't
have to rebuild a local copy each time
you do a project so you can update it
and basically if you just run the same
come in it will just update what you
have instead of rewrite right archive
PubMed the first time it prepares the
disk it downloads everything it cleans
it up and then it archives it splitting
it up the next time it sees that all
that's already been done and it sees
that there are only a couple new files
so it ignores all the ones that have
already been download in process and
just downloads incrementally so you know
daily or weekly you could run it and it
will should take a few minutes to
complete one of our colleagues did
chimed in though
and that is that you do have to rebuild
each year with the new base with a new
PubMed PubMed baseline right I would
assume that's great yes great I think we
have we've gone through most of this
stuff ok great thanks everybody for
coming and Jonathan thanks a lot for
this webinar this was great and we'll
talk to you later